aaron
you need to be here
[Music]
for the funeral we're expecting you
you knew him didn't you i'm an old mate
of luke's actually
i'm just here in a personal capacity
luke drove to his house at 4 30
killed his family then headed here they
kill himself
you're convinced he did it what do you
think
it's all over town that you're reopening
the investigation who's here it's the
pigs
you of all people should be minding your
own business
what are you doing back in our town boy
so you've heard some stories about me
i've had some you have personal history
with the girl who died in a river 20
years ago are we
here's a connection between the two
deaths where were you that afternoon why
would i lie
because luke asked you to i need a
suspect put them under enough pressure
and they just crumble
this has got nothing to do with me you
don't know me
sometimes when this place feels kind of
[Music]
i think you're gonna empty the truths in
a town like this
[Music]
when you've been lying about something
for so long
it becomes second nature
it's a revenge trip we have one chance
we have truth
under the milky way tonight
[Music]
you